let's go to our caller from oh I don't
know there's so many people oh you know
what let's go to Terry from Newton Terry
from mutant here in town Terry what's
going on hi David how's everything going
good good so I just wanted to call in
because there's been a lot of talk about
the early exit polls so as you saw like
in Massachusetts alone the exit polls
said that Bernie was gonna win with
about thirty percent of the vote and it
turned out he actually was Biden who won
with I think about thirty two percent
yes and as a result there's been a lot
of talk about it some people I think are
you know confused and probably it was a
lot like what happened in 2016 where
some of the early exit polls said
Hillary would win states that she ended
up not winning but then there's also
other people like on redacted tonight
that have gone really in-depth and said
there's like some like rigging of the fo
and yeah I just wanted to know what your
take on this was like is it just a bad
example of you know exit polling and the
fact that we need to like really review
how we do it or is it more like
something sinister is going on and
Bernie needs to be more aggressive about
it listen here here's here's the thing
so the big picture with the exception of
Donald Trump in 2016 it's always you've
got the people who lose who say that it
was it was rigged in some way Trump said
it was rigged despite the fact that he
won he insists that he didn't actually
lose to Hillary by three million votes
that's kind of a special case I at this
point can't make the case in good faith
that the exit polls are definitely a
poll discrepancies are definitive
evidence that there was vote tampering
voter machine tampering or whatever the
case may be when you look nationally I
don't know if it's two or two point one
or two point two million votes Biden is
crushing Bernie in the popular vote and
these margins that are being looked at
when it is proportional allocation of
Delegates this is the really important
thing it's not it's not all or nothing
when you look at some of these
discrepancies even if you can make the
case
as I've seen it made that there's like a
four-point swing a five-point swing that
doesn't really make sense
you Biden would still be winning by a
slightly smaller margin so I don't I'm
not saying that to dispute or confirm
any particular theory but what I'm
saying is I've not seen and I'm willing
to have my mind changed I've not seen
anything that I would call sort of a
remotely definitive evidence that vote
tampering is what explains Joe Biden
winning by 2.2 million votes nationally
okay that sounds about right because
there's been people loving like throwing
that around and redacted tonight like
they add this guy on who's apparently
some expert in elections although I
don't if I asked like people like
professors in law - they probably would
strongly disagree with that it's just
I'm just worried because you know
there's some people who are like trying
to use that as like a pretext that you
know saying that progressives can't win
and I think it's tough because you know
especially like there's a lot of like
voters who Bernie have energized who
don't trust the electoral process to
begin with and if they have this feeling
that basically everything's going to be
rigged against them and like other like
Bernie Kratz then they're absolutely
right yeah yeah that's not a program I'm
familiar with and I wouldn't be able to
speak to what they've said but certainly
the the rhetoric you're describing will
will help Trump and matin you know some
people may be okay with that it's just
it's a it's a strategy disagreement it's
a it's just a disagreement is all it is
you know yeah well I mean what we're
answering my question David my pleasure
my plan I would you yep all right wish
you to see that's best of luck during
this part crisis likewise absolutely
teri great to hear from Terry and Newton
that does it for calls today as always I
apologize I am NOT able to meet the full
demand of the phone calls that come in
but we will of course take your calls
again